Kelly Clarkson
and I have to say that because my Steve
Carell said Kelly Clarkson so that's how
you you're referred to in this house um
you have probably my favorite female
voice of any artist besides Stevie Nicks
and I'm not I am not bsing you right now
[Applause]
the nicest thing ever to say thank you
I'm not trying to stating facts I know
well it's nice the fact is nice and I
appreciate it and that's that's it means
a lot because all those people you just
listed off are people that I I not only
grew up listening to I still listen to
um because I'm a Spotify playlister um
but but I I I just love that like you
have such credible music that you love
so that means a lot like coming from you
um your voice is like has your like
other worldly and no one sounds like you
and you can sound like anything and you
can sing anything and um it's pretty
remarkable you are welcome on my show
anytime like I feel really good about
myself on Instagram so I I watch you
doing Kelly and I'm like damn that girl
is good damn
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]